[Music]
you've probably heard of the human
genome the huge collection of genes
inside each and every one of your cells
you probably also know that we've
sequenced the human genome but what does
that actually mean how do you sequence
someone's genome let's back up a bit
what is a genome well a genome is all
the genes plus some extra that make up
an organism genes are made up of DNA and
DNA is made up of long paired strands of
a's t's c's and g's your genome is the
code that your cells use to know how to
behave cells interacting together make
tissues tissues cooperating with each
other make organs organs cooperating
with each other make an organism you so
you are who you are in large part
because of your genome the first human
genome was sequenced ten years ago and
was no easy task it took two decades to
complete required the effort of hundreds
of scientists across dozens of countries
and cost over three billion dollars but
someday very soon it will be possible to
know the sequence of letters that make
up your own personal genome all in a
matter of minutes and for less than the
cost of a pretty nice birthday present
how is that possible let's take a closer
look knowing the sequence of the
billions of letters that make up your
genome is the goal of genome sequencing
a genome is both really really big and
very very small the individual letters
of DNA the a's t's G's and C's are only
eight or ten atoms wide and they're all
packed together into a clump like a ball
of yarn so to get all that information
out of that tiny space scientists first
have to break the long string of DNA
down into smaller pieces
each of these pieces is then separated
in space and sequenced individually but
how it's helpful to remember that DNA
binds to other DNA if the sequences are
the exact opposite of each other a z'
bind to T's and T's bind to A's G is
bind to C's and C's to G's if the 80 GC
sequence of two pieces of DNA are exact
opposites they stick together because
the genome pieces are so very small we
need some way to increase the signal we
can detect from each of the individual
letters in the most common method
scientists use enzymes to make thousands
of copies of each genome piece so we now
have thousands of replicas of each of
the genome pieces all with the same
sequence of a's t's G's and C's but we
have to read them all somehow to do this
we need to make a batch of special
letters each with a distinct color a
mixture of these special colored letters
and enzymes are then added to the genome
we're trying to read at each spot on the
genome one of the special letters binds
to its opposite letter so we now have a
double stranded piece of DNA with a
colorful spot at each letter scientists
then take pictures of each snippet of
genome seeing the order of the colors
allows us to read the sequence the
sequences of each of these millions of
pieces of DNA are stitched together
using computer programs to create a
complete sequence of the entire genome
this isn't the only way to read the
letter sequences of pieces of DNA but
it's one of the most common of course
just reading the letters in the genome
doesn't tell us much it's kind of like
looking through a book written in a
language you don't speak you can
recognize all the letters but still have
no idea what's going on so the next step
is to decipher what the sequence means
how your genome and my genome are
different interpreting the genes of the
genome is the part scientists are still
working on while not every difference is
consequential the sum of these
differences
is responsible for differences in how we
look what we like how we act and even
how likely we are to get sick or respond
to specific medicines better
understanding of how disparities between
our genomes account for these
differences is sure to change the way we
think not only about how doctors treat
their patients but also how we treat
each other